c'est l'enjeu des transports et et je
dirais de l'acè de de de l'adaptation
des conditions de circulation
particulièrement en Île-de-France
pendant les jeux je me bornerai à
indiquer deux points sur l'offre de
transport collectif puisque c'est en
principe c'est l'essentiel des trafics
c'est de l'ordre de 600000 à 800000
personnes par jour supplémentaire venu
pour les jeux spectateurs titulaires de
billets euh on est dans un un schéma qui
est à peu près stabilisé avec un plan de
transport qui prévoit plus 15 % en
moyenne d'augmentation des capacités par
la RATP la SNCF et les autres opérateurs
de transport en Île-de-France ou en
France
entière de toutes les zones pour
lesquelles on a des capacités de de de
transport qui vont être assez
contraintes la zone ouest avec le Parc
des Princes Le Rolland Garos où il y
aura le même jour pendant plusieurs
journées deux intersessions sur le Parc
des Princes deux intersessions sur le
Roland Garos avec des croisements flux
des gestions de de de de de mobilité
extrêmement complexe à organiser des
moyens importants à mettre en terme de
facilitation pour rentrer des et
circuler dans les dans les lieux de
d'épreuv euh un plan national de
mobilité qui va être mis en en place
d'ici la fin mars au plan national qui
reprendra les les données de chacun des
sites et les et et naturellement toutes
les conditions d'accès dans notre pays
dans les aéroports dans les gares euh
les renforcements des moyens au postees
de contrôle frontalier et cetera et euh
enfin euh un un document qu'on appelle
le TDM le travel demand management qui
est un document de de de gestion de la
demande de transport permettant
d'informer les Franciliens puisque là il
s'agit d'Île-de-France uniquement euh
sur les les conditions euh
d'encombrement ou de les difficultés
d'accès sur certaines lignes qui seront
plus chargé que d'autres et donc leur
permettant de planifier leur plan de
déplacement euh domicile travail
notamment ou pour d'autres enjeux de
manière anticipée puis ensuite de
manière g en temps réel pendant les Jeux
donc ce dossier des transports mobilité
est considérable et il repose aussi sur
des priorités pour nous d'accessibilité
des transports et naturellement de
bonnes information des
publics